Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain a fantasy drama film
called “Marriage Simulator.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
In the opening scene, we are introduced to a
beautiful Japanese girl named Chiharu Takajo. She
is stranded at a bus stop because of the pouring
rain. A young man, Yuichi Tokunagi gets off a bus
and joins her. He tries to start a conversation
with Chiharu but she is dismissive of his efforts.
Yuichi takes the hint and quits talking. They
wait for the rain to stop in complete silence.
But after waiting for several minutes, both of
them get bored. Yuichi notices a film’s poster
behind them and comments that he had always
wanted to watch it. Chiharu also claims that
she hasn’t watched a movie in a long time. The
pair goes silent again but Yuichi takes a chance
and asks Chiharu to go out on a movie date with
him. She is left stunned and is quite nervous
about going out with a stranger. But Yuichi
doesn’t give her a chance to answer and runs
to buy two tickets. Chiharu smiles at him and
the two start to date from that day onwards.
They are so madly in love with each other
that after dating for only a few months,
they decide to get married. A wedding planner
gives them a tour of a chapel and briefs them
about the anniversary gift services they provide.
The couple buys a package where their anniversary
gifts till the tenth year of their marriage will
be sent by the company. The gift for the tenth
anniversary is a customized video that they will
have to shoot for their future selves. Chiharu
excitedly compares the videos to a time capsule,
however, Yuichi is not so confident about it. Yet,
he agrees to participate for his fiance.
In the following scene, they shoot the videos
professionally. Yuichi awkwardly asks
the camera about their tenth anniversary
while Chiharu leaves a delightful message for
a thirty-five-year-old Yuichi. That evening,
they go to the wedding planner to finalize
their venue. As they talk, Chiharu notices
an advertisement for a package that the company
provides. It describes a special program that
helps a couple to take a look at their future life
with each other. The planner says that the program
is called the marriage stimulator and most couples
use it to find out if they are really compatible.
He asks them if they want to apply but the pair
is skeptical. When Chiharu returns home that day,
she and her roommate talk about her upcoming
marriage. According to her roommate,
the couple is making the decision hastily. Chiharu
claims that they are happy in their relationship
and know that they are making a good decision.
The roommate jokingly gives the example of a
dress that Chiharu impulsively bought some
months ago and wore only once. She suggests
Chiharu think about the marriage again because
they have been dating for only a few months.
When she expresses her relief about not marrying
her former boyfriend, Chiharu starts to question
her decision. To be absolutely sure about
marrying him, she decides to apply to the
marriage stimulator program and convinces Yuichi
as well. In the following scene, they are at the
company’s headquarters discussing the program.
The officials explain that the scientists can
predict how the couple’s marriage life will
be by examining their DNA, their medical data,
their personal background, and their character
profile. This way, their future married life is
stimulated in the form of a dream and shown to the
couple. Following that, they acquire Chiharu and
Yuichi’s blood samples and several medical
data, along with their background history.
Then the two are seated in special chairs and
a device is attached to their heads. The doctor
warns them that the future they see through the
device is not absolute and might change according
to their emotional reactions. Finally, the
device starts, and they are made to fall asleep.
At first, the couple dreams about their wedding
day. They stand in front of the guests who cheer
for them, happily stepping into the next part of
their lives. The first morning after the wedding,
they wake up and are just as happy. Chiharu has
made breakfast for Yuichi that the two enjoy
together; that is until they realize that they
prefer different side dishes with their breakfast.
It is only a small compromise that the two
have to make but it doesn’t end there.
Chiharu discovers that Yuichi always leaves the
toilet seat up which causes a minor argument,
again, one of them has to compromise. When they
go to sleep at night, Chiharu has the habit of
leaving the lights open but Yuichi cannot fall
asleep with them on. In the same way, as time
passes, the couple eventually realizes that their
lifestyles are very different from each other.
One day, Chiharu has enough of her husband not
listening to her, so she tells him that she feels
unappreciated. Yuichi, on the other hand, puts
the blame on her for never dressing up, putting
on makeup, and looking pretty. Following that, the
couple is woken up for a break. They are clearly
not happy after watching what their future will
be like. They try to be optimistic and assume that
they will eventually get used to living with each
other. Yuichi says that no matter what happens,
he will not leave her side. While going down
the elevator, they come across another couple
who has also just seen their future. The girl is
crying because the man is about to cheat on her.
He tries to explain that he would never do
something like that but the marriage stimulator
has already predicted the future. Sometime later,
they continue the stimulation and dream of Chiharu
being pregnant. They discuss the possible names
for their child and decide to name it Haruki
if it is a boy and Yuka if it is a girl.
In a few months, Chiharu gives birth to
a beautiful boy. Her mother-in-law calls him
Yutaro. Chiharu looks at Yuichi uncomfortably,
asking him why his mother is calling their son
a different name. The woman laughs and claims
that according to their family’s tradition, the
first kid should be something with the letter Y.
Yuichi doesn’t want to go against his mother so he
just accepts the name while Chiharu is furious at
him for not mentioning this before. On their fifth
anniversary, Chiharu prepares him a dinner at home
and waits for him for hours. Yuichi comes home at
midnight and says that he has already eaten at a
business dinner. Chiharu is clearly hurt and upset
but Yuichi is dismissive of her effort to make him
happy. She suggests they go out for dinner the
next day, but Yuichi has to attend a golf match.
Chiharu remembers the day they had met for the
first time and reminisces about how good life was
then. Chiharu finally tells him that she is hurt
to which he replies that he works hard to provide
for the family, so she should be happy instead.
He harshly asks her to stop bitching so much
and be satisfied with what she has for once.
In the following scene, the couple is talking
about Yutaro’s school fees. Chiharu wants to
start working to be able to provide their kid
with better things but Yuichi insists he already
earns enough for the family, Chiharu accuses him
of trying to keep her in the house because
he doesn’t want her to grow professionally.
The two get into yet another argument and start
yelling at each other. They both argue that they
have sacrificed a lot for the family but are
oblivious of what the other person has done.
As their screams start getting louder, poor Yutaro
comes to their room crying because he is scared.
Chiharu quickly gets up and calms him down. As she
is hugging the kid, Yuichi approaches her and says
that they should separate for good. Chiharu just
hugs her son tighter and cries. In the next scene,
they finally sign the divorce paper. Moments
later, the pair wakes up in the chair. The
officials ask them about their experience but
they stay frozen in their seats. After composing
themselves, they get up and confront each other.
Chiharu is beyond hurt by what she just witnessed.
She slaps Yuichi, calling him a liar for promising
that he will always stick by her side. Yuichi has
nothing else to say. He simply claims that it
is better they know this before their wedding
because now they can take a step back and prevent
themselves from wasting time on each other.
With that kind of future, they do not want to
marry anymore. Yuichi asks his wedding planner
to cancel the ceremony. The officials are
shocked but they respect the pair’s decision.
Chiharu returns home but she feels like she
is missing a part of herself after breaking up
with Yuichi. Her roommate tries to console her and
advises her to never marry because all men change
after marriage. But the advice does little to
nothing to help her mood. For the next few days,
she keeps herself busy with work. If she is free,
she either goes swimming or hangs out with her
friend to keep the thought of Yuichi out of her
mind. One day, she returns home to see that she
has received a package from the wedding planner
that contains the video Yuichi was supposed to
give her on their tenth wedding anniversary. As
she contemplates playing it, she gets a call from
Yuichi. It turns out that the company accidentally
sent them the opposite tapes so he asks her to
throw them away. Chiharu says that she will, but
after the call, she can’t help but play it, hoping
to see him one last time. In the video, Yuichi
greets her and apologizes for all the mistakes he
has made throughout the years. He admits he can be
non-communicative sometimes and claims that even
though he doesn’t say it, he loves her a lot.
To Chiharu’s surprise, he also confesses that
the time they met at the bus stop was
not the first time he saw her. In fact,
he had seen her at the train station one day and
instantly knew she was the one. Following that,
he always looked forward to seeing her around the
neighborhood. He wanted to approach her but never
had the guts until he saw her at the bus stop
that day. He had even left his umbrella on the
bus so he could spend some time with her. Yuichi
ends the video by telling her that they should go
to a movie theatre and see if they are showing a
romantic film, if they are by chance showing one,
that will mean that they were always meant to be.
By the end of the video, Chiharu is left sobbing.
She has a hundred things going on in her mind.
Without thinking much, she runs to the movie
theatre that they went to on their first date. To
her disappointment, it is showing a horror movie
instead of a romantic one. She is about to return
when Yuichi also arrives there and asks her to
come to the movies with him. The pair smiles
at each other and reunites. Then, we find out
that they have been watching the stimulation till
now. Them canceling the wedding was also a part of
the simulation. The couple opens their eyes, still
trying to comprehend the rollercoaster of emotions
they have felt in the past two hours.
They get up from their seats and do not say a
word to each other. The planner congratulates
them and asks them about the experience,
still, the pair doesn’t speak. In the following
scene, we see them walking down a park. They have
not talked to each other since watching the
stimulation. After walking for a long time,
they hold hands and smile at each other.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.